comme tous les jours estelle s'occupe de
ses protégés cela fait huit ans qu'elle
a monté son élevage de chevaux elle se
lance en 2009 look 4 hectares de prés un
particulier et installe une petite
cabane pour le matériel un rêve devenu
réalité mais aujourd'hui menacé le
bailleur était même trajet un homme très
gentil et ça se passe est extrêmement
bien pendant deux ans et puis au moment
de son décès c'est sa femme qui a repris
l'exploitation et du coup elle a
souhaité que je parte je suis expulsé
par après décision de justice tribunal
paritaire des baux ruraux
donc je suis condamné à partir de là où
je suis après cette décision en décembre
estelle se met en quête d'un autre
terrain pour accueillir ces 40 chevaux
de sport et poneys de loisirs elle fait
appel à la safer d'île de france mais
aucune de ces candidatures n'est retenu
pour alerter sur sa situation elle fait
une grève de la faim pendant dix jours
et un collectif de soutien voit le jour
le collectif a lancé la pétition en
ligne pour essayer de toucher un maximum
de gens et pour a essayé d'alerter les
pouvoirs publics oui j'avais démarré une
grève de la faim
j'ai été contrainte d'arrêter pour
raisons médicales mais que si j'avais je
ne vois que ça bouge pas je serai prête
à reprendre malgré tout cela banon je
vois pas d'issue favorable pour moi si
ce n'est à terme une disparition de
l'élevage si je ne retrouve pas de
terrain
aujourd'hui dans l'impasse estelle
redoute d'être expulsée d'une semaine à
l'autre
une situation qui touche également sa
fille impliquée dans l'élevage
j'aimerais surtout que des personnes se
rendent compte de la situation
qu' il puisse nous aider mais moi si je
fais mon futur travail qui qui seront en
compte que et maintenant elle y en a pas
un problème
contacté par nos soins l'avocate de la
propriétaire ne peut donner suite à
notre demande d'interview
lancée il ya deux semaines la pétition a
déjà recueilli plus de 1600 signatures